the Xbox Series X launches this holiday
season and ahead of that Microsoft has
dropped a ton of new information on top
of what we already knew about the
next-gen console there's plenty of juicy
new details to comb through and talk
about here's everything we know so far
first new features the Series X uses
quick resume which is an evolution of
the game suspension feature you can
utilize on Xbox one the series X can
simultaneously suspend three or more
games at a time letting you seamlessly
jump between them what's more those
games will load much faster on the new
console versus the x1 you can see the
faster load times in action in this new
video from Microsoft Microsoft is also
introducing what it calls smart delivery
if you own a game on Xbox one you
already own it for the series X all
first party Microsoft titles will
support smart delivery while third-party
developers can make the decision to
include the feature for themselves
we know that halo Infinite and Gears 5
will both support smart delivery and in
Gears case you'll see better textures
and lighting on the series X plus
potential 120 FPS support for
multiplayer the series X will also add
HDR color to games that release without
it and there will be plenty of games
moving into the next generation the
series X is backwards compatible with
all four Xbox consoles the full
backwards compatible library of original
xbox and 360 games currently available
on Xbox one will transfer to series X
and X one games will make the jump two
you can play all those games with the
series X's new controller which is very
similar to the current gamepad but with
small yet important tweaks for one it
actually has a share button it's also
more ergonomic thanks to rounded bumpers
and a d-pad that combines the
traditional cross design with the newer
disc shape the new controller will also
work with the Xbox one and vice versa
you can use your current controllers
with the series X if you wish let's talk
specs Microsoft spilled the beans on
some very technical details the series X
has 12 teraflops of performance and 16
gigs of GDD are 6 memory it's
performance target is 4k resolution at
60fps
up to 120 FPS for its CPU the console
sports 8 zen 2 cores at 3.8 gigahertz as
for storage it includes a one terabyte
custom nvme solid-state drive with USB
3.0 support for external storage you can
hook up your own SSD or HDD but you
won't be able to play any of those
external games unless you use
Microsoft's new proprietary memory cards
that is Microsoft and Seagate have
created external drives that come in
small metal cartridges these use
Microsoft's quote velocity architecture
which lets game developers utilize SSD
memory as RAM Microsoft was apparently
unhappy with how standard SSDs
compromise speed when heated up so it
partnered with Seagate for this external
solution so you can totally store games
on your own drives but they'll need to
be copied to the series X's internal
storage or one of these expansion cards
if you actually want to play them that's
everything we know so far about the
Series X Microsoft is holding a game
stack panel this week so stay tuned a
game spot for any additional information
that comes out of that
you
[Music]